joining us now is Fox News national
security strategist and former deputy
assistant to President Trump Sebastian
Gorka and author of the Geraldo show Fox
News correspondent at large for Aldo
Rivera all right
gentlemen I understand Geraldo that what
the president said about ms-13 was in
reaction to what someone had said before
about those ms-13 gang members and
that's why he called them animals even
you a smart person like you Geraldo were
caught off guard thinking that the
president was talking about everyone as
as animals take it back
well the president's remarks were
released piecemeal by people who were
criticizing the president for using
those hot-button words like animal and
when I first read it it was not in the
context of ms-13 it was just I you know
I thought he was talking about
immigrants generally and it was very
disconcerting to me and I complained
about it then I heard from Sean Hannity
and and others and said no read the
context of the entire remarks I was not
working that day so I read the context
of their remarks and then I quickly
amended my statement I still think that
when you use hot-button words like
Savage or animal you've got to be
extremely careful that you're not
demonizing an entire group and I think
that that's what the Democrats seized on
I think the president in some cases
creates more problems for himself than
it's worth but I do believe that every
effort should be used to crush ms-13 the
president's absolutely right they are a
menace
just as the Bloods are a menace and the
Crips are a menace you know these other
just like the Mafia was a menace and the
Russian mob is a menace they are they
are horrible people they have no right
to be in the country we want they want
them behind bars or deported for sure we
just have to be careful not to paint
with a broad brush
you know dr. Gork Oh what when I was a
judge I sentence someone not as I recall
I think it was a murder sentence and I
call the guy in animal I said he belongs
in a cage which is where I was sending
him at the time to prison and I got a
lot of heat for that you know I think
that one
reasons that people love president Trump
and those he's elected is because he's a
straight talker if you take a baseball
bat to a 16 year old and a machete and
cut somebody up you are an animal
and the most frustrating part is that in
I believe it was 2014 when there was
this big influx from Central America
they were coming in and they were saying
I am a Latin King I'm ms-13 I got all my
tats here and we were letting them in
should we have hey look I'm a little
disappointed with Geraldo's you know
non-apology
Geraldo you've met the president how can
you even pause it for a millisecond that
he thinks all immigrants are animals
he's married to an immigrant it's absurd
the fact that he was taken out of
context isn't an accident the New York
Times and CBS had headlines where they
said he called undocumented immigrants
animals that's a lie these people are
animals he talked about ms-13 gang
members this is an organization that its
name comes from the violent initiation
ritual that you have to go through to
become one of their killers so yeah
judge it's amazing to have a president
who finally talks to the truth and has
common sense and that's why he connects
with the American people who know these
people are killers and animals
Geraldo should President Obama have let
them in knowing who they were and and
everybody knows that to be a member of
him as 13 you need to kill somebody and
generally rape someone in front of
someone else and then kill her
shouldn't the president of lifetime ban
bed I think that historically judge we
have to set the stage here was it no but
but what I want to talk about ms-13
ms-13 was really identified as this
menacing organization relatively
recently in 2004 during the I knew they
were animals in 2014 we all knew they
were animals now President Obama let's a
minute said you've got Johnny 14 I I
think that the problem with this is not
a chance
laboratory remarks like let me let me
finish my say the problem with
inflammatory remarks like dr. Gork errs
attack on me just now is that it
obscures the big issue what is the big
issue we we as we as lawyers and and
people who care about law and order we
want the federal state and local
governments to use every tool in their
possession to crush these criminal
organizations they are organized
criminal organizations who have no place
in American society you want them
crushed immigrant or documented
undocumented so much of legal citizens
gangbangers have to be crushed they have
no place in American society my point is
very simple when you talk about ms-13 a
tiny sliver of the 11 million odd
undocumented immigrants the danger is
that you paint with a broad brush it
isn't baloney
it isn't baloney you may not agree with
me but it is when why do you think the
Democrats had the opening to attack the
president taking him out of control say
because you've got to be extremely
careful no it's just like this like of
the Italian people complained so
bitterly for so many decades have they
were being painted by the broad brush of
mafia it was a stigma that weighed
heavily on the italian-american
community this the ms-13 every
respectable Latino in this country wants
ms-13 a relic you do and that's why
we've got to be straight shooters I have
to say but I I want to finish this
Geraldo when the truth is that the the
immigrants legal immigrants illegal
immigrants the chambermaid the person
who's waiting on you the person's plenty
of them they want them gone so let's
call them what they are I don't care if
somebody misinterprets it is about time
we said this is right this is wrong this
is this is you know this is legal this
is illegal
I just want us to stop making everything
about right left
red blue this is something that everyone
should stand united
Latinos come to this country the vast
majority law-abiding hard-working
they want to be part of the American
dream they don't want these to be you
know rapists and murderers every survey
indicated and they stay here and
nobody's looking to get rid of those
people
it's the criminals and the animals of
ms-13 you and I are absolutely in sync
as we usually are coming up thank you or
although